Retrieval Augmented Generation,
or RAG, has become a key
method for getting LLMs
to answer questions over a user's
own data. But to actually build and
productionize a high-quality RAG
system, it costs a lot to have
effective retrieval techniques, to
give the LLM highly
relevant context to
generate his answer, and also
to have an effective evaluation framework
to help you
efficiently iterate and
improve your RAG system, both during
initial development and
during post-deployment maintenance. This
course covers
two advanced retrieval
methods, sentence window retrieval
and auto-merging retrieval, that deliver
a significantly
better context of the
LLM than simpler methods.
It also covers how
to evaluate your LLM
question-answering system with three evaluation
metrics, context relevance,
groundedness, and answer
relevance. I'm excited
to introduce Jerry Liu,
co-founder and CEO of LlamaIndex, and
Anupam Datta, co-founder and Chief Scientist
of TruEra. For a
long time, I've enjoyed following Jerry
and LLamaIndex on social media
and getting tips
on evolving RAG
practices. So I'm looking forward to
him teaching this body of knowledge
more systematically here. And Anupam has
been a professor
at CMU and has
done research for over
a decade on trustworthy
AI and how to
monitor, evaluate, and optimize
AI app effectiveness.
Thanks, Andrew. It's
great to be here.
Great to be with you, Andrew.
Sentence window retrieval
gives an LLM better context by
retrieving not just
the most relevant sentence,
but the window of
sentences that occur before
and after it in the document. Auto-merging
retrieval organizes the document
into a tree-like structure
where each parent node's text is
divided among its child nodes. When meta child
nodes are identified as relevant
to a user's question, then the
entire text of the parent node is
provided as context for the
LLM. I know this sounds
like a lot of steps, but don't worry, we'll
go over it in detail
on code later. But the main takeaway is that
this provides a way to dynamically
retrieve more coherent chunks of text
than simpler methods.
To evaluate RAG-based LLM apps, the
RAG triad, a
triad of metrics for the three
main steps of a RAG's execution,
is quite effective. For example,
we'll cover in detail how to compute
context relevance, which measures how
relevant the retrieved chunks
of text are to
the user's question. This helps you identify
and debug possible issues with how
your system is
retrieving context for
the LLM in the QA system.
But that's only part of the
overall QA system. We'll also cover additional evaluation
metrics such as groundedness
and answer relevance
that let you
systematically analyze what parts of your
system are or
are not yet working well so
that you can go in in
a targeted way to improve whatever
part needs the most work. If
you're familiar with the concept of error
analysis and machine learning, this has
similarities. And I've found that
taking this sort of systematic
approach helps you be
much more efficient in
building a reliable QA
system.
The goal of this course
is to help you build production-ready,
write-based LLM apps. And important
parts of getting production
ready is to iterate
in a systematic way
on the system. In the
later half of this course, you gain
hands-on practice iterating
using these retrieval
methods and evaluation
methods. And you also
see how to use
systematic experiment tracking to
establish a baseline and
then quickly improve on
that.
We'll also share some
suggestions for tuning
these two retrieval
methods based on
our experience assisting
partners who are
building RAG apps.
Many people have worked
to create this course. I'd
like to thank, on
the LlamaIndex side, Logan
Markehwich, and
on the TruEra side, Shayak Sen, Joshua
Reini, and Barbara Lewis. From
DeepLearning.ai, Eddie Shyu
and Dialla Ezzeddine
also contributed to
this course.
The next lesson will give
you an overview of what you'll
see in the rest of the course. You'll
try out question-answering systems that
use sentence window
retrieval or auto-merging
retrieval and compare
their performance on
the RAG triad,
context relevance, groundedness, and answer relevance.
Sounds great. Let's get started. And
I think you people
are really clean up
with this RAG stuff.
Laugh on it.